hey guys welcome to nerding out shown
which we gather up gamespot nerds to
talk about shows they like on today's
episode we're talking about walking dead
season 7 episode to the well i'm here
with Aaron Spencer gadje and I'm buddy
let's get right into it guys this
episode horses zombies faces chopped off
it was a whole bunch of fun we got to
meet got to meet King Ezekiel we all
talked about that last week um so what
did you think when you saw him in I mean
he was definitely a character like you
was out there like just full-on like
fantasy world setting like accent and
everything just trying to pretend like
he's this crazy king and it was kind of
interesting watching Carol have to meet
him and try to figure out like what the
heck am i lookin at right now this see
where she slowly like smiles so tell me
dear lady what do you think of your kid
she's just like this place is great
great I don't want to upset you so what
is okay he's doing something that is
pretty cool with Whitney and I really
got a lot of enjoyment out of the fact
that they're they're sending than poison
pigs what do you think about that whole
scenario like negan is he's not killing
these people you've got killed him at
the same time like they do you know it's
a whole nother rival group does Oliver
setting like there were stirring of
other people in if you wanted to fight
but Kings ecol doesn't want that like he
knows he cares too much about his people
that he knows that if they go to war
there would be a slaughter he doesn't
want to deal with that and so I think
this is their own subtle way of being
like we can obey his command but we
don't have to like it like just a little
indirect gestures any these little
poison pigs their way I think it's I
think it's pretty crazy I also think
that the the obvious parallels between
Ezekiel and Meegan more kind of
hilarious like negan was screwed up as
it is is just putting on an act he's
he's not mean I don't know if in his
dreams it like he dreams about himself
beating people's heads in with bats and
really loves it but I'm guessing his
weird trollee smile about the whole
thing I think he's just trying to keep
order the way that he thinks he needs to
keep order and the weird part about
Ezekiel is he's doing the exact same
thing he thinks like people he actually
you know he actually mentions it his
leadership style is this
this whole like distant suspension of a
reality thing and also he's got a tiger
which is I mean that kind of badass it's
pretty badass yeah all right so anything
else about that like what about what
about you guys what do you get what he
gets think can eat any just additions
about Ezekiel I you know zekiel to me is
it I think is gonna be quite interesting
character to watch I like how that he
know he's and he's not buying his own
performance he tells Carol this himself
so I think that's really cool he kind of
realizes that you know this is all bs
but definitely putting on yeah he's
definitely show but he's doing it for
the best first people I like that right
alright so um Carolyn Morgan uh we
mentioned Carol uh what about Carol
Aaron what was what was going on with
his episode oddly enough I thought one
of the media story lines in this was not
there was a dude with a tiger it was was
happening with Carolyn Morgan so the the
moment where you realize that Carolyn
Morgan are starting to change roles so
up until this point Carol's whole thing
is I'm gonna leave this group because I
don't want to have to kill for this
group anymore if I stay here I'm going
to have to kill somebody like in being
in this episode she's going through that
whole like oh my god zombies or people
to thing where like she literally starts
seeing the people who the zombies were
Morgan on the other hand his whole thing
is I will not kill other people for you
and he thinks he can have it both ways
but halfway through this episode he
starts kind of getting friendly with
Ezekiel screw and a fight goes down he
immediately points a gun which he
doesn't even like guns at somebody on
Megan's crew and then he realizes what
he's doing and he realizes he's starting
to be willing to kill for Ezekiel and
he's doing what Carol kept warning him
to do so i think there's this really
interesting role reversal happening on
where happening where Carol doesn't want
to kill anymore and she means it and
Morgan says he doesn't want to kill but
he's starting they're starting to be
cracks in his philosophy is like Aikido
philosophy so that was really cool um
and then Ezekiel sort of has a different
relationship with both of them but i
think what Ezekiel's relationship with
them boiled down to was he's lonely like
I think i think is he killed I mean
Ezekiel he takes kerala side at one
point he's like real talk like I'm not
like this I
let people make this stuff up like I
kind of just want to have a moment where
I can let my guard down with you so I
think Ezekiel's a little bit exhausted
by his own responsibility and but he's
gonna keep it up because that's what
keeps his career life and that whole
performance has got to be exhausting as
well it's like oh man I'm glad you guys
are here because you guys don't buy my
crap i can tell a pomegranate my lady no
I'm cool bro I don't want to lay before
the pomegranates you weirdo so alright
this episode kind of just it it
definitely changed the momentum episode
1 of the series was like ah and then
then we had dudes riding around on
horses and everything was you know
fluffy buttercups what do you think
Spence yeah I mean episode 1 was
fantastic we had obvious we had two
desks but this episode just really it
kind of changed momentum and obviously
we're getting closer to the war we're
getting close to that fight but it would
have been nice to kind of continue that
momentum this war between yeah nyan nyan
screw in Mexico and everyone's crew and
we kind of get just of that with the
poisoning of the pigs so we kind of get
ok cool so zeikos not buying this either
but it would have been nice to continue
that kind of momentum I felt like this
was too long of a setup episode even
touch into it at all yeah have to say
six all move it's like just give us an
idea like keep it going yeah so yeah I
know about the rest of you but for me
personally I was like I was kind of
bored now say ah come on I mentioned it
before it's the chapter in the book that
you just like dude this is just fill or
no one cares yeah on a river and like
thinking about his love life like get
get get to the point we got it yeah read
a lot of fantasy book says was a parent
with that so I think all of us cool I
think also in this episode Carol kind of
was the lantern that they'll writer just
hung on this whole episode like her
cracking up the entire time was really
making it okay for you as the audience
to be a little bit uncomfortable with
everything that was happening cuz let's
be honest it was kind of awkward yeah
I'm kind of to be honest I was I was
annoyed by her like I don't want to kill
people anymore like this that's what the
show is about that's why everyone's
watching it because there's zombies like
you kill zombies that's what that's what
the that's what the thematic is like now
you don't want to be on the show anymore
lady is that what's happening cuz that's
how you that's why we can't have
nice things alright so the preview for
next week I'm not really sure what uh
what the timelines were but Daryl's in
prison actually Spence why don't you why
don't you talk a little bit about that
what you see yeah so what we saw was
Darrell's in prison the white looks like
to be looks like his handler and it also
looks like maybe two white might be
leaving the group e season getting on
the bike he's about he's ready to leave
I like the compy white it's yeah
seriously d white Dwight so but but then
there's also an interesting woman as
well there who seems to be informing one
of the characters and you who knows who
this person is could be one of negan
wives and speaking of negan you also get
a glimpse as to what it's like in his
stronghold people are bowing down to him
as he walks around so is he a god or
they just do it because they fear him
it's interesting to kind of get that
idea so who knows there's two kings yeah
there's two kings so anybody else
anybody else and you have predictions I
just want to see what they do to Daryl I
gar they're gonna try to break him down
and like convert him like like Dwight
like became like his loyal lapdog for a
lot and before that it seemed like he
wasn't and time curious are they trying
to turn Darryl like make him one of
their own or what are they gonna do to
torture Oh hmm it is a prison dad will
be tortured find up next week but maybe
next month we have no idea guys thank
you for watching for more on your
favorite comic books TV shows and movies
keep it locked to gamespot universe